living in the desert we're bound to see
wild animals in our neighborhoods but
what happens when you find
one stuck in your backyard one las vegas
couple
reached out to channel 8 for help so we
asked what others would do
in a similar situation sasha loftis
joining us live tonight with those
answers
brian coyotes can spell dangers for
small sweet dogs like this but what
happens if the coyote itself
is in trouble the couple we spoke with
today found themselves in a situation
just like that what started as a normal
friday
for mary and steven smith changed after
one
startling discovery i came out to let my
dog
out and and i noticed
a big other dog and it was a coyote
a coyote injured and stuck in their
backyard
we didn't know what to do we're not i'm
not i don't know anything about coyotes
the smiths made several calls and got
nowhere
that's when they contacted channel 8. i
said someone has to help us like this
is crazy we got a hold of several local
rescues
who wrangled the animal and safely got
him into a crate
for a trip to a wildlife veterinarian
so what would you do if you run into a
similar situation
in your neighborhood the more they build
the animals don't have nowhere to go
because you building in homes but yet
you tearing down
their home experts say reach out to the
nevada department of wildlife
if they can't help turn to rescue
organizations for advice
and as for these two animal lovers they
call this
experience something they'll never
forget he's safe
and those guys came and got him and i'm
just oh my gosh
and they hope it encourages others to
step in
and help all our community's creatures
now if you find an injured animal in
your backyard you can contact the nevada
department of wildlife or the u.s fish
and wildlife services that number
702-515-5230
we have that phone number and contacts
for local animal rescues that can also
help in situations like this
that's on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now